I read that you and your wife were on
this terrifying Lufthansa flight it
dropped what four thousand feet seven
thousand feet something yeah you said it
dropped four thousand feet what does
that feel like
you're suspended disbelief I mean it's
zero gravity the your red wine
and the glass and the plates that your
food was on are all suspended floating
still just in the air and to look at it
for that long which wasn't that long
with one two three four one and then
everything just comes crashing down yeah
it was it was a hell of a scare a
complete loss of control you're complete
a 100 feeling of I am not in control I
have no way to get control of this
situation in the moment did you look at
each other did you say anything to each
other right after yes I mean it actually
uh my trade table is what held me down I
did not have my seatbelt on
um and there was not a seat belt warning
right before it happened yeah I just
immediately reached over
made sure Camilla had her seat belt on
held hands there just saying okay is
that it is there another is there
another one coming another one did come
it was it was odd you hear people's
reactions some people were ghost silent
some people had a big bursts of laughter
and it was not like oh this is fun it
was like I just gotta do I'm in shock
and then you know how it is on a plane
if you see the the flight attendant not
looking extremely confident you're like
oh
it's the only place my eye goes the
flight attendant always right
reroute to route to Washington Dulles um
that night was on my way to Vietnam
actually which I finally did make it but
yeah it was um it was the hairiest
flight I've ever had by far and I'm
assuming your kids were not on the
flight no they were not so thank God for
that you know you can't help but put
yourself in the position of you and
Camilla right the two of us would have
like we would have assumed that this was
it this was the end and we would have
been glad that we were together but we
would have been
filled with sorrow that we couldn't say
goodbye to our kids and is the will
updated and who did we leave our kids to
again like all of that comes into your
mind right well I didn't project that
far ahead I didn't do that much math now
that you say it I think most of that
stuff is in line
I I also as a person who's not a pilot
my mind goes to the actual engineering
of the plane the steel and it buckled
and you go how can something withstand
that I happen to have a friend of mine
sitting next to me who was a pilot wow
he was calm as could be he was like and
I was like can the plane hold that and
he was like these things are so tested
that yes don't worry about the plane
structurally it can hold that that was a
big relief do you always fly with your
own pilot just in case now on I always
have my own Pilots right
the life to the left the pilot to the
right you know people always say God is
my God is my co-pilot Matthew's like no
my co-pilot is actually my co-pilot
I did check and I was like if
something's wrong can you can you fly
this thing and he was like no problem no
problem and I was like great love to
hear that that's a that is a valuable
friend Albert we have to talk I'll give
you a parachute yeah Albert Albert would
access the emergency exit whether it was
needed or not and just we would all get
sucked out one at a time
foreign